what's the difference between now duty
because because you've been in the game
for so long
what is the difference now in the comedy
business that's different than it was
back in the day oh it's so much better
now I mean you know number one it was a
white male dominated thing and then it
was really this there was a lot of kind
of generic hacky white guys [ __ ] it was
like all these guys were Blazers rolled
up to the elbow and the bolo ties in the
80s yeah yeah a lot of men and women
relationship stuff and now it's great
there's there's so many brilliant female
comedians there's just every ethnicity
and and sexual orientation and there's
so many great voices now you know and in
all these different countries - I've got
that's the great thing about me doing
the international circuits for 20 years
is I have great comedian friends of
every ethnicity and sexual orientation
and all over the world Wow and it's I
really love that yeah there's also
different ways of getting your stuff out
there that wasn't available to you in
the 80s like I don't like to make you
know to make it out yourself you know I
could do that concept and you know it's
you know you can make a podcast you can
it's it's so much better now in every
way yeah it's so you know the podcast
taught me and tiger belly for fans I
love you but it got me closer to my real
fans yeah people discovered me on just
this didn't even know what I did in the
past and when they come to the show riot
there's a different level of connection
they were my shirts you mean they could
say the little lingos either Georgia is
a pink dick or nosotros papaya or
whatever I like they call me slap King
from this from the audience and what I
do a meet and greets afterwards some
people come to get what kind of
emotional and I like that I like doing
they know personal details about you
it's really incredible to get emotion
and you know it's the thing I love about
comedy you know it's you know it's
really like an exclusive club of fighter
pilots the people who can do it and the
people who can do it very well is even
smaller and it doesn't matter if you're
rich or poor or black or white or
whatever you know it just matters if
you're funny so yeah it's the thing
about it that I've always loved it's the
it's the great equalizer
it's funny that you say that because
there was times where I thought anyone
can do it in my head I'm not true it's
not true but still I thought why just
get up there and do it especially
getting through those first ten years
where you're struggling and not making
any money
why that's most people can't get past
the first year but there was a couple of
young people that hang out at the store
you know there's a like young guys and
girls hang up a story that's never done
stand-up but they want you can always
tell who they are because they're just
always there and you ask hey do you do
stand-up and they go yeah but we want to
but you know that's why I come all the
time or whatever it might be and this is
one dude I keep every time Andy I'm
there he's there and for the last year
I've been saying dude have you gone up
Yeah right which makes me realize it I
guess it is difficult oh my god twelve
times no no I was forced to do it to him
I know but you went up well god that's
why in my head I'm like oh she's brave
he wanted to conduct a social experiment
because I I think that I'm a fairly
eloquent person so he was like okay fine
you know why don't you try standup a
couple times I got up there and it was
the most agonizing experience of my life
number one I wasn't funny nothing
I was I had garbled speech or people
sweating just like a maniac I've had
people say she was good no I was
terrible I was absolutely he's terrible
people come up to me I saw that guy it
was so humbled and it made me appreciate
so much what he does day in and day out
and I never want to ever ever do that
again so the experiment has to be over
it but you did 12 time that part of you
thank you it was terrible he's done it
but he was great he's great
you were young yeah the only one that
hasn't done it in this room is Bryce
yeah his time will come
it's like your chemical you know
[Music]